what's happening there reject nation
that felt weird to say because i'm
usually sitting right here and hearing
it but now here i am on the real rejects
and i am very very excited for this
episode of koi's comic corner without
greg or john this feels very strange but
regardless of the lack of gregor john
please leave a like and subscribe and
click that bell to get notified when the
next video is up now all of this is
about a huge announcement a leak that
doesn't typically happen with marvel the
thunderbolts has been leaked an
announcement that rarely happens where
marvel didn't formally announce
something but it turns out the rumor is
that jake schreier is directing a
thunderbolts property this is huge
rarely do we find anything out for
marvel that isn't carefully curated this
makes a lot of sense and a lot of
companies are i think falsely touting it
as marvel's answer to the suicide squad
now we're gonna get into that we're
gonna get into who the thunderbolts are
we're gonna get into a possible lineup
of the things assembled to date that
might make up the thunderbolts we're
gonna talk about who the possible
villain might be why i think the
thunderbolts would be a game changer for
the mcu and of course some comic
recommendations for you folks if you
want to know these characters as well as
i do before you get the thunderbolts
movie let's get after it all right so we
know who the director is theoretically
but who are the thunderbolts so the
thunderbolts are a team from the comics
that are really interesting because
they're under the guise of being a super
team a lot of the avengers a lot of the
defenders a lot of fantastic four but
they're actually villains trying to
basically rip off small towns or make
superhero antics profitable they're kind
of heroes for higher but more
shenanigans are involved but what's cool
about the thunderbolts is slowly they
kind of develop a moral compass these
characters with powers these characters
that have often gotten away with doing
horrible things of their powers start to
realize the error in their ways and they
can become good that's some of the arcs
in other arcs there are times when they
stay villainous in other arcs there are
times that they stay
villains for the sake of their leader
and actually become heroes etc there's
about 10 different thunderbolts teams
this comic's been around since the 90s
and it's had about 42 main members and
upwards of 80 various members depending
on the size of the team so this is a lot
of reading i'm trying to streamline for
you guys because it's hundreds and
hundreds of issues of comics but
basically the thunderbolts are a team
that has that darth vader i am your
father twist where the american public
or you know the european public or
wherever they're doing their heroism
gets revealed like oh no bullseye was
helping that wasn't actually daredevil
etc so i think the difference between
this and the suicide squad is that
basically the suicide squad are known
villains that are trapped doing certain
things for the sake of their own
survival so it's literally just
survivalism whereas the thunderbolts are
a team that are working under the guise
of being good guys and the average
public doesn't know they're bad and
that's a huge huge important difference
because i think we're leading to a
different era in the mcu where heroes
aren't as beloved we've had tastes of it
with civil war we've had tastes of it
with i think where we're going with miss
marvel and most importantly i think it
all leads to the biggest next shift in
the mcu the x-men unless there is a
powder keg for a world that hates and
fears them the x-men don't work so yes
every single time someone talks about
marvel inevitably the x-men come up
anything in phase four inevitably people
want the x-men but i do think
specifically the thunderbolts is the
gateway between miss marvel and where
we're going with the x-men that's where
we are now with my theoretical opinion
of why the thunderbolts matter let's
talk about who might be the thunderbolts
from what we've gathered so far in the
mcu possible members i think i would
have them do a kind of big five to
mirror the original avengers back in
phase one where you have that beautiful
shot of all them gathered together i
think it'd be beautiful symmetry to have
that like we've been hoodwinked these
aren't heroes after all i think they
might even try to do it in movie where
they confuse the audience i think they
might gather these heroes and then make
you realize oh no i've been rooting for
villains so i think they might go elena
belova as black widow they might go us
agent as captain america and they'll
have some interesting commentary there
because we have an audience if you watch
the show have seen him do horrible
things but in the real world there's
lots and lots of ways to manipulate
people's opinions even though you've
seen them do horrible things you've also
got abomination who i think is going to
be the you know hulk parallel we've got
ghost who we last saw in ant-man who's
an actual member in the comic books i
think that's our first new completely uh
original ip member of this new avengers
team we've got taskmaster who's a very
important member from the comic books
but i think deserves a bit of a
redemption arc i think of any phase 4
movie black widows taskmaster situation
is the thing that's most maligned and if
you haven't noticed marvel does a very
good job reading message boards and
going like oh no we messed this up let's
fix it a la thor the dark world look at
thor's dark world look at what they did
the avengers infinity war and endgame
movies and tell me they didn't go okay
we read that message board i think they
might do the same with taskmaster by
having taskmaster be a very important
part of this thunderbolt situation and
basically retconning and fixing a lot of
the issues we all have at that character
i also hope and this is the most i went
in order of insanity the craziest pitch
would be if you need an iron man you
need someone that's a crazy sleazy
impossibly charming arrogant tech
billionaire sam rockwell bring back
justin hammer and his tanned hands give
me an iron man that is not doing things
very selflessly give me that selfish sam
rockwell that just wants to profit he'd
be perfect in thunderbolts that's not
cannon to the comics but you know who is
is whiplash whiplash is a huge character
from the comics and i doubt mickey
rourke and his bird want anything to do
with this franchise so instead you pluck
sam rockwell and that's the team i would
assemble also in the comic books winter
soldier is a key member often leading
the team which i think would be a really
interesting twist if they have winter
soldier maybe be the villain of the
story what if the relationship with a
certain character i'm about to talk
about and winter soldier causes a bit of
a oh no we don't know which side to root
for because we like these guys winter
soldier maybe we think he's brainwashed
again maybe we're not sure where his
allegiances are but that's because of
baron zemo baron zemo is typically the
big reveal leader in the comic books
he's under the guise of this character
citizen 5 citizen 5 or v i only read it
i'm not sure how it's pronounced i don't
know if he's referred to a citizen
fiverr citizen v but basically that
character is revealed to be baron zemo
and that's how we find out these heroes
we've been following are in fact
villains the american public i mean i
think by the end of the show when they
call it captain america in the winter
soldier we see beren zemo who he's loved
and has been charming is still
duplicitous is still capable of evil
things i think it'd be really fun to
have him as the villain as he is the
core thunderbolt leader but in addition
to that we do have norman osborne as the
leader at times we have had even the
punisher as the leader of the
thunderbolts and the one you're gonna
read a lot about in the internet is
general thunderbolt ross now thunderbolt
ross isn't the leader until like the
fourth or fifth iteration of the
thunderbolts but i do think thunderbolt
ross would be a very interesting
captivating choice because it would deal
with the military industrial complex
it'll deal with the commentary from the
civil war about the government against
heroes it would deal with a lot of the
commentary we're living through now
where it's like what do we do with these
systems of power who do we trust so
obviously we we have lost william hurt
that does complicate things i don't know
if they would want to do a general ross
all cgi would he stay red hulk with that
glorious mustache and maybe some voice
over would we have a new military
character basically playing a parallel
to thunderbolt ross any of those things
are options but i do think the most
likely is baron zemo and that would
allow some fun friction with winter
soldier and he's already in these
properties collecting black widow and
u.s agent and these things i think that
is the most likely scenario and i really
want to see daniel brule back and
playing around with morality
duplicitousness and overall being
charming and us being like i like this
guy why am i rooting for him he's doing
horrible things now the question is we
have the team assembled we have our
potential leader but who are they
fighting i don't think winter soldier
will be the main core villain i think
it'll be a hiccup i think it'll be a
problem i think it'll be something to
solve but what i think they're gonna do
and what i hope they do what i would do
is we met a certain officer at the end
of miss marvel that we'd already met in
no way home you should recognize that
cop officer whatever you want to call it
the department of damage control they've
turned from in the comics a cleanup
agency we briefly saw them in spider-man
homecoming they're the people that took
away vultures livelihood they're the
people that took away all of his assets
because that's what they do in the comic
books they clean up after superhero
supervillain fights it's a really cool
concept there was actually fun fact
almost an abc show about the department
of damage control i think we saw the
long game they were going to include
them in the movies and that's why that
show is crap but i digress the
department of damage control seems to
also be a bit of a policing force the
department of damage control i think is
going to start going after heroes that
are under age i think the effects of
civil war are still following up into
phase four we've got lots of cosmic
things going on we've got battles with
gods we've got lots of huge threats but
if you're doing a marvel property you
still need the ground level threat the
beautiful thing about the mcu and the
thing that keeps the comic book so
interesting is while you're in the sky
you're also still in the ground you've
got characters like punisher you've got
characters like spider-man you've got
characters like miss marvel that handle
jersey city threat while you have those
things you need a government situation
you had cap'n and hydro but you also had
cap versus shield i think when the
sokovia accords didn't go through
now those same people that want
superheroes registered that want
superheroes made illegal that want
registration around human beings which
is a very very very important
conversation to have about what it is to
be made illegal what you do is we
couldn't make it so masks are illegal
because there's barely any masks in the
mcu that's what differs from the comic
book so we had those sakovia chords or
is basically iron man versus cap about
registration they can carry that on into
this new team of young avengers who are
gonna be wearing masks who are gonna be
underage and the question doesn't become
can these people with powers act it'll
be can these people that aren't adults
yet make decisions that affect the world
what do you do with someone that's 16
that has the power to blankety blank
what do you do with someone who can lift
a car if they can't yet drive one what
do you do with that and that's what i
think they'll have this registration act
be now and in the comic book there's a
huge precedent for this it's called
kamala's law if you watch our video
reacting to episode one i do cover
briefly kamala's law in the essence of
it basically being the champions which
are a very important team in the comics
they're more street level but they're
also much more political they talk about
climate change they talk about voters
registration rights they handle
day-to-day human city issues and the
champions one of them gets hurt miss
marvel kamala khan and when she gets
hurt they are able to mask this thing
called kamala's law when they pass
kamala's law it means miles morales it
means viv vision who's a young female
vision the daughter of vision it means
all of these wasps all of these young
superheroes that are friends with kamala
are now hunted in her name she's in a
coma it is extra painful because not
only is it dragging her name through the
dirt while she's in a coma but they're
worried about her friend and they're
hunting people under the name kamala
which is a very very interesting feeling
of what do we do about this while not
revealing our friend's identity what do
we do about this while we're also still
trying to have regular lives what do we
do we're kids we can't turn to the
adults so it's a very beautiful
spiritual sequel and direct sequel to
civil war both in the comic books and i
think in the movies and who better to
hunt down the young avengers than a team
of heroes that are registered that are a
more official police force that are then
revealed maybe in movie to be bad guys
and that allows us the audience to go
okay now the young avengers have someone
to fight it's not good guy versus good
guy it's good guy versus good guy that's
actually bad guy i think it'd be an
incredible twist to see these heroes
revealed to be villains and that gives
credence to our young avengers for
fighting them and it makes us all
realize that just registering them isn't
enough that there needs to be
accountability beyond these things and i
think it'd be a very interesting story
about the importance of some legislation
and the importance of trust i think by
the end of the thunderbolts we're going
to set up a world where some heroes
might be illegal where some heroes
aren't trusted where we can have a world
that hates and fears them setting up the
x-men and i think it all starts with
episode two of miss marvel which is
coming out right now i almost guarantee
you we start to see groundwork laid
throughout ms marvel and we might even
see kamala's law passed by episode six
setting us up directly for the
thunderbolts this is huge this is winter
soldier level getting us to the point
where shield unravels setting up
everything in phase three i think phase
four is much more cohesive than people
are giving it credit for i think we're
getting a lot more properties and
therefore a lot more breadcrumbs we just
don't see what that loaf of bread is yet
that bread's cooking and it's coming and
it's going to be awesome that's what i
think thunderbolts is going to be i
think it's going to be a big bait and
switch i think it's going to be really
special for the mcu and i think it's
going to lead to even bigger things so
yes we don't have an avengers right now
but i think we're gonna have young
avengers i think we're gonna have a
thunderbolts and i think it's gonna blow
people's minds when those characters are
revealed to be villains and that's why
they're different than the suicide squad
i'm so excited i cannot wait to see the
thunderbolts it's a comic team i love
from the books i would recommend you
check out not just the original run from
mark bagley some of the most beautiful
stuff with baron zemo running the
thunderbolts check out the more recent
dark rain run where norman osborne is
running them and if you want a more
x-force-centric team there's a really
fun run with deadpool elektra and those
characters you're probably more familiar
with that came out in 06 or thereabouts
so there's a lot of great stuff that
one's called marvel now thunderbolts you
can find that in a trade paperback form
if you guys want any recommendations any
specific issues or arcs leave a comment
below i'll try to respond to it or tweet
at me etc i'll give you guys more
thunderbolt recommendations if you want
them but i would check out the original
run mark bagley art it's long it's
glorious i would check out the norman
osborne dark rain stuff and i would
check out the marvel now stuff with
deadpool on the team those are the three
runs i think we might pull some
influences from we'll see when
thunderbolts drops hopefully in the next
two years it's exciting stuff we'll see
if this league's getting more coverage
at d23 i feel like they're gonna make an
official announcement in the coming
months well this was my first solo video
hopefully you guys enjoyed it it was
literally just me talking but for the
record greg was here the whole time
all right like subscribe leave a comment
turn that bell on other youtube things
thank you reject nation for welcoming me
with open arms thank you for loving
those first two videos and thank you so
much for not saying screw this guy talks
too fast about comics too much we don't
want him on the channel cause i
appreciate being here much loved you
guys see you next time
[Music]
you